viens bonsoir des gonades spécial vichy
ce soir donc les rondes du national sont
les plus importantes sont terminées on
va y revenir tout de suite mais avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet tout à
l'heure avec que yossi dorfman qui
gagnent entre le parti on reçoit deux
joueurs importants de cette
manifestation en d'abord le
vice-champion de france puisqu'il était
vice champion de france l'année dernière
david marciano grand maître
international dont soir david passa
alors un tournoi qui est difficile cette
année pour toi cauchemardesque je crois
ce serait plus précis
bon mais revenir tout de suite je
présente le deuxième invité qui jean-luc
chavanon alors qui est déjà venue dans
l'émission il ya deux jours ou trois
jours je sais plus et qui par contre a
fait de très bons résultats puisque
maintenant tu es jean-luc en tête tout
seul du tournoi accession donc en bonne
position pour se qualifier pour le
national de l'an prochain oui donc oui
ça se passe très très bien pour
l'instant donc bon c'est pas encore fini
mais c'est parfait pour l'instant on va
y revenir tout à l'heure puisque on va
analyser et à partir d'aujourd'hui qui
était crucial et tu as battu le leader
ou le coleader avec qui tu partager la
première place
aujourd'hui on va revenir tout à l'heure
david e marciano on va revenir son
parcours cette année puisque l'année
dernière a priori tous les espoirs
étaient permis pour toi second qui avait
perdu en finale contre tienne bacrot et
cette année difficile
alors comment ça s'est passé non en fait
ça s'est passé mal au début j'ai eu du
mal à gagner des parties c'est à dire
qu'en fait j'ai fait point d'abord
devenu le bon sens entre autres au
problème la troisième j'étais gagnant
contre le jour le plus faible du tournoi
j'ai pas gagné c'est déjà un premier
problème
après je n'ai pas encore réussi à gagner
je n'ai fait que des nuls et la partie
décisive où je devais gagner pour me
qualifier
j'ai été gagnant encore et
j'ai raté le gain et après en fait j'ai
pris tellement de risques que j'ai perdu
une position de noël et puis bon je me
suis retrouvé en poule basse donc
finalement ça te n'y a pas grand chose
mais la formule a changé par rapport à
l'année dernière et l'année dernière
s'était fait tu sais comment c'est
méthodes ne le sais pas c'était deux
qualifiés seulement et après des demi
finales et des finales en deux parties 1
et médiation directe donc c'était une
formule beaucoup plus vivante les
joueurs se battent est beaucoup plus
c'était c'était différent cette année
la plupart des gens de penser surtout à
finir dans les quatre premiers c'est un
système avec quatre qualifiés et en fait
c'était différent comment moi je préfère
une ancienne formule tu l'avais dit
avant je dis pas ça parce que j'ai
vraiment de bons résultats mais toute
façon vu comment j'ai joué je ne serai
pas qualifié avec l'ancien mais est-ce
que tu analyses déjà taux rajusté de
cette année due à peut-être une mauvaise
préparation où étais tu es en forme ou
alors c'est vraiment les événements qui
sont ligués contre toi oh il ya un peu
de tout moi je n'étais pas en forme
c'est sûr mais résultat ces deux
derniers mois dans les tournants rapide
et assez catastrophique donc je le
savais j'ai joué quand juste avant j'ai
fait un résultat moyen en jouant très
mal euh bon suit les événements n'ont
pas été très favorables c'est vrai aussi
parce que j'étais pas loin de me
qualifier finalement mal calculé une
variante dans la dernière partie où j'ai
vu le coup gagnant j'ai calculé géré at
j'ai vu une défense pour lui alors qu'en
fait j'avais une contre pointe donc
c'était ça s'est joué à rien ma
qualification mais de toute façon mon
pour le titre cette année même si
j'avais gagné cette partie ça aurait été
très difficile et bouzid et peut-être
pas très bien de préparer non plus enfin
mon chaque année j'arrive après avoir
pris des vacances détendu et reposé ça
nous réussit donc je pense pas que son
pays se dire que ça le problème vraiment
d'accord donc en tout cas bon ben si ça
sert à toujours d'expérience on peut le
dire comme ça est ce que cette année tu
as fait d'autres bons résultats suite à
ton titre enfin de vice champion de
france l'année dernière
quelles ont été tes meilleurs résultats
alors depuis mon titre de vice-champion
de france j'ai très peu joué deux
parties langer pas vraiment fait de très
bons résultats en fait j'étais assez
mauvais aux championnats d'europe mais
bon les conditions étaient très
difficiles toute l'équipe de france a
souffert des conditions
en géorgie après j'ai fait un résultat
correct en équipe j'ai joué beaucoup de
tournois rapide où j'ai fait
d'excellents résultats jusqu'en mai de
janvier à mai j'ai gagné presque tous
les tournois que j'ai joués même
détourna fort et après ça s'est
détériorée assez rapidement sans que je
sache trop pourquoi et mai dernier
aspect t'es pas bon effectivement donc
je suis assez moyennement confiant
surtout après mon tour dans l'arène
alors quelle est ta position
actuellement dans la poule dans la poule
basse à combien de points
j'ai quatre sur dix j'ai toujours pas
gagné de partie c'est la première fois
que ça m'arrive je crois depuis 12 ans
dans un tournoi d'échecs incompris
depuis tous les chapitres france il
reste une partie de même qu il reste
encore une partie demain donc peut-être
que ce signe tu veux la jouer pour la
cour je tiens pour mon public pour moi
hier j'ai joué une partie marathon j'ai
joué jusqu'à 11h30 10 soit rejoué 128
coup pour essayer de battre fontaine
tout le monde me demandez aujourd'hui
pourquoi j'avais joué aussi longtemps
une finale nul pour d'abord elle était
pas aussi nul que ça d'ailleurs dorfman
était le seul à penser que c'était pas
si facile à défendre et
et puis bon je voulais tellement gagner
que j'ai vraiment pas pensé une seconde
à proposer nul il a fallu attendre 11
heures et demi d'histoire pour m'y
résoudre voilà en tout cas encore une
fois ça démontre que c'est nationale est
de plus en plus difficile et que c'est
pas parce qu'on a été vice-champion une
année qu'on peut récidiver l'année
suivante forcément c'est pas c'est pas
facile du tout c'est vraiment le niveau
est très élevé alors tu restes à vignoux
david évidemment parce qu'on va
commenter tout à l'heure une partie très
importante qu'à jouer donc que jean luc
le chabab qui avec nous ce soir j'en ai
accepté une partie que tu as joué contre
lupu qui était en tête du tournoi et
c'était très important pour la suite de
lait des événements oui c'était une
partie très importante d'ailleurs donc
pour la petite histoire on peut dire que
la partie j'ai joué hier déjà contre
arnaud jaffré
j'ai joué pour gagner cette partie
j'ai joué une partie très très long qui
a duré six heures 6h15 et le but de
gueye est de gagner cette partie la
veille c'était évidemment de concept de
prendre la tête du tournoi est également
d'avoir les blancs d'obtenir les blancs
contre lupu c'est à dire si j'avais fait
match nul hier j'aurais joué avec les
noirs donc je voulais absolument avoir
l'avantagé de la couleur est aujourd'hui
donc j'ai décidé le disons que j'étais
pas vraiment parti pour gagner cette
partie j'étais partie pour voir ce qui
se passait et
c'est un joueur très solide
habituellement et il a joué in east
indienne sama ça m'a surpris alors j'ai
attaqué et ça a passé
ça passait encore une très belle partie
d' attaque on va voir ça quels sont les
autres joueurs qui maintenant peuvent
prétendre aux premières places dans ce
tournoi accession comme une bonne avance
déjà j'ai un demi point d'avancé donc
tout seul devant avec un demi point
avant ce oui c'est la deuxième ronde où
j'ai un demi point d'avancé donc bon
pour l'instant c'est une petite avance
confortable
ce qui est bien c'est que c'est que les
poursuivants sont de moins en moins
nombreux donc j'ai un poursuivant qu'il
ya un demi point
j'ai un troisième il ya un troisième
joueur qui est à un point et après il ya
énormément de joueurs qui sont un point
et demi donc voyez un peu le break et un
peu fait quand même là on peut dire oui
qui a un petit break qui a été fait
sachant que ces deux premières places
qui compte
tu as un point d'avancé sur le 3e donc
c'est a priori c'est bien c'est bien
parti c'est bien parti oui d'accord
alors qu'elle est le deuxième une
troisième on peut dire le nom du
troisième joueur c'est c'est [ __ ] nos
salles un je ne sais pas comment premier
et le second est le second c'est slim
belkhodja qui qui fait un très bon
tournoi
d'accord alors on va voir tout de suite
maintenant on a la chance évidemment
d'avoir deux très forts jours avec nous
enfin luc chavanon qui je rappelle a
fait une deuxième nombre de grands
maîtres saman donc elle est proche du
niveau de grands maîtres et david
marciano vice champion de france en
titre donc encore pour 24 heures c'est
ce qui m'a dit ça leur est donc grand
maître international aussi donc on va
pouvoir voir cette partie donc entre
jean-luc chavanon et au look ou s'ils
sont prêts non c c
mais sergio sert de sergiu popa revenir
vite pour qu'on puisse voilà donc il est
donc à l'origine c'est un joueur
d'origine roumaine romaine d'accord donc
france roumanie
on va voir ça donc c'est parti tout de
suite avec donc d4 g6 alors tu as
préparé cette ouverture on va on va voir
les premiers coups sûrs et lorlanges qui
nous qui recourent aux manettes
pas du tout on peut dire que j'ai si
c'est la première surprise de look ou il
d'habitude il ajouté quatre dessins qui
je devais ouverture très très solide
apparemment jeu on m'a dit qu'il a joué
ce coup parce que disons qu'il avait un
ascendant psychologique il m'a battu
plusieurs fois en partie rapide et y
pensait peut-être pouvoir prendre des
risques aujourd'hui donc il a joué g6 et
là j'ai joué ces quatre comme comme
deuxième coup et tu es tu t'y attendais
à cette ouverture
je m'y attendais pas mais quand je joue
c'est 4 je lui réserve une petite
surprise
disons que là j'ai envie de j'ai déjà
l'intention d'anticiper une défense
avait une unité française et indienne et
de jouer la vente que j'ai joué plus
tard on va voir la suite donc cavalier
fiscale et ses trois fous en g7 le cas
donc ça c'est une ouverture classique
les blancs occupent le centre et les
normes aussi le contrôler à distance ses
seins exactement donc des 6es la s4
alors ça c'est une variante très aigu de
l'estonienne savants des camions oui et
ça c'est très très sauvage exactement
donc bon ils vendent que j'ai préparé
que j'aime bien il ya un jour du
national qui est un grand spécialiste un
des meilleurs spécialistes au monde de
cette variante c'est un atelier weiser
donc mais seulement david a joué
aujourd'hui contre contre anatoli mais
ça n'a pas été cette période parce que
tu avais les pistes noires si j'avais
les normes et ne saurait pièce est grand
mais je joue palestinienne moi je suis
un peu comme beaucoup je joue d
ouverture très solide mais je suis je
penserai je suis très étonné de son
choix parce que je pense que c'est un
peu inconscient quand on sait que la
première qualité de jean-luc ce qui fait
sa force c'est son jeu d'attaqué
jean-luc quand il attaque il est
redoutable
il a hélas bon il a comme tous les jours
d'autres défauts mais c'est vraiment son
point fort donc laissé à jean-luc ce
style d'opposition c'est quand on est
justement un joueur qui aime beaucoup
les positions de tranquille
c'est étonnant vraiment étonnant alors
on va voir donc il a un peu trop laissé
jean luc s'avancer on va voir ce qu'il
se passe
d'un petit rock du côté noir cagoulés f3
des coûts de développement normaux pour
l'instant où j'ai 80 c'était peut-être
déjà une surprise ou g4 et cinven
secondaire c'est un coût qui n'est pas
très joué mais déjà ça montre qu'il
n'est pas préparée à l'éventualité donc
de cette attaque des quatre pions il
n'est pas préparé et il essaye de sortir
des lignes et de jouer on va dire de
jouer un plan original pour pour me
perturber un petit peu mais il se trouve
que j'ai déjà joué ce genre position il
ya pas longtemps et que et que là
j'avais exactement en tête le type de
placement bias a utilisé dans ce schéma
d'accord d'habitude on joue plutôt en
avance et de pian le pion c'est cette
enseigne c'est ça disons que dans cette
position on commence à réagir au centre
avec les noirs il est temps de réagir
donc voilà dans cette position il
apparaît agile et je fous g4 et je joue
faux oeufs 2 donc j'anticipe donc la
prise du cavalier en f3 et mon fou qui
serait placé plus tard en f3 pourrait
pourrait jouer sur la grande diagonale
donc h 1 à 8 et éventuellement donc
prendre le pion bessette enfin préparer
la poussée de cinq d'accord donc on va
voir la fiche je rappelle que c'est et
loire lange qui était aux manettes qui
peut intervenir à tout moment puisqu'il
a le micro et qui fait kiffer sur les
coûts en fonction des coûts de nos
commentaires
donc eu 4 e 5 alors là ça y est c'est en
engagent le combat tout de suite puisque
là il ya une un contact entre les
chaînes de pions ben je pense que comme
il commit ça serait comme il fait rien
au centre ben je commence à m'y
installer j'ai développé une pièce il
joue un petit coup il joue ses six parce
que s'il peut pas jouer c'est 5 à cause
de tout simplement de pions procès 5
avec une finale qui est qui est assez
désagréable pour lui par exemple où je
peux jouer eux 5 et h3 voilà en cas de
600 puis emprunt c'est ça je pense que
je peux prendre et probablement je sais
pas si j'ai changé d'âme tout de suite
mais en tout cas je vais faire mais ils
sont fous g7 par eux 4 5 et est aussi je
vais pouvoir essayer d'échanger sur
fouquet cap par h3 et donc j'aurai des
bonnes pièces d'accord des bonnes pièces
alors son fou g7 sera enfermé par les
pions blancs exactement d'accord et la
paire de fou dis moi je ne l'accepté pas
possible d'essayer de jouer en pro f 3
et le 5
vous prenez 3 3,5 pour justement éviter
que tu joues à cinq quand même
oui mais je pense que je vais encore
prendre le pion et je suis pas sûr qu'il
le récupérera facilement ouais c'est sûr
que ce n'est pas facile mais si tous les
jours de 5 c faut qu'ils réagissent de
toute façon donc voir les possibilités
la loi nous montre les possibilités qu
aurait pu survenir dans la partie suite
à la suggestion de david marciano alors
on va revenir la partie donc je couds g4
le coup donc un peu inattendu c6 et e5
donc attaque lecavalier 6 il le cavaly
retourne sur la case 17e' l'attaqué et
la hache 3 donc la saison il n'a pas
trop le choix il est obligé d'échangés
je voulais le forcer immédiatement
échangé les fous parce que donc j'avais
vu l'astuce que j'ai joué un petit peu
plus tard et je voulais pas lui laisser
la possibilité de casser mon centre avec
ses 6 et 5
à aucun moment donc je décide de prendre
la terre de feu immédiatement
d'accord donc là maintenant le flou en
f3 empêche c6 c5 à cause de fou prend 17
exactement d'accord donc vous prenez
trois dames b6 donc là il sort sa dame
sur une case assez active finalement
puisque fait pression sur b2 et un petit
peu sur des quatre aussi donc oui
apparemment quand il joue d'un v6 on a
l'impression qu'il veut empêcher mon
développement ils vont empêcher le petit
rock mais on verra que ce n'est pas
possible on va voir on va comprendre ça
dans deux coups un petit rôle quand même
alors ah oui alors tu disais il veut
empêcher parce que si on prend 1,5
si on joue donc des six points en cinq
sets qu'il a joués à il a joué ça si je
reprends du pion f
évidemment je perds le pion le pion aux
5 parce que parce qu'on peut prendre le
pian avec lecavalier avec le cavalier
parce que l'option de d4 ne peut pas
reprendre puisque le roi et sort est un
échec par la dame mais bon
malheureusement je vais quand même
installé un gros centre en jouant le
coin intermédiaire c4 c5
voilà qui attaquent la dame et après
d'amd 8 tu vas jouer le coup pion f
prend 1,5 l'avait donc des points
centraux que tu estimes très fort donc
là où il ya une position très
confortable
actuellement ces seules chances de
contre je sais f7 f6 et b5 b6 essayer de
casser le centre d'accord mais le
prochain coup je crois que j'ai joué
interdit quasiment toutes ces
possibilités pendant quelques comptes
car oui disons que f6 tout de suite et
pas possible parce que eux aussi s'ils
gagnent 17 donc les noirs en fait on pas
vraiment le temps de souffler dans cette
position il faut qu'il trouve un coup
mais après claudia 6
il ya des mauvais 3 et là on bouge plus
on mange dames les trois voies la séance
un peu le pendant d'un v6 de tout à
l'heure ça m'intéresse et les blancs qui
mettent leurs dames sur cette fameuse
case et qui fait pression sur la case
bessette est aussi 28 ans sur la case f7
qui lorgne un peu sur le roi à leur tour
des huit
il protège le pion bessette et la fouge
et 5 alors la foule je saigne ça ça
embête les noirs sur le pion aux 7 c'est
ça oui là dans cette position on a un
festival de pions de pions clouer tous
les pions sont cloués dans cette
position donc les noirs ne peuvent pas
bouger d'une oreille donc voilà le sais
tu ne peux pas bouger puisque la dame
fait échec au roi et le pion recette
peut pas bouger puisque c'est le fou qui
prendrait la dame noire donc là on a
deux pions cloué à un terrain clos et
d'absolu et un clouage eu un peu moins
absolu mais quand même très embêtant on
peut dire qu'à ce moment là j'étais
assez confiant sur le sur mon choix
d'ouverture et sur ce qui se passait bon
évidemment il faut quand même gagné la
partie alors david comprendre que j'en
dis que sa confiance j'ai rarement vu un
grand maître se faire massacrer aussi
vite comme ça c'est terrible cette
position j'estime aussi david que la
déjà pas cette position elle est
objectivement perdu mon gérant il faut
il y aller perdre évidemment il faut il
faut il faut il faut finir le travail
mais elle s'est fait écraser après ses
cinq je pense déjà
c'était il se faisait applaudir c'est
une victoire au moins dans le début pour
les blancs c'est une victoire c'est un
avantage considérable d'accords donc
effectivement l'impression donc les
blancs ces salons l'avantagent consiste
surtout à la main mise sur le centre ça
il a la mainmise sur le centre il a des
pièces beaucoup plus active il a un
avantage d espace considérable il
contrôle vraiment il joue il a cinq
rangées à lui alors que l'adversaire
joue sur trois rangées seulement ont
suffi de regarder d'ailleurs s'est coupé
en deux exactement
je tire développement espace à chaque
aucune pièce quelle bonne case pour
l'adversaire en face et c'est un vrai
cauchemar
il semblerait que non un des gros
problèmes de développement puisque on
voit mal comment ne serait-ce que lier
les tours en bougeant la dame ça paraît
déjà très difficile le cahier 17 a pas
de case donc déjà vraiment c'est très
dur pour les noirs c'est vraiment donc
là ensuite dont on va voir les coups
suivants droit d un doctorat d'état on a
largement le temps de commenter ça
tranquillement
tu auras des 1 donc là ça protège bien
la base alors c'est important ça on
protège la base de la chaîne document
c'est ça oui il y en d4 il est
fondamental en plus la tour sur la
colonne des peut éventuellement
intervenir s'ils jouent p 7b 6
j'envisage éventuellement de jouer fou
prend ses six s'y prend ses cinq de
bouger madame est d'essayer
éventuellement de menacer tout
simplement pu reprendre ses 5es de
gagner le cavalier 17 qui serait cloué
se retrouver par la tour d un qui
courait le cavalier 17 sur la dame oui
ce serait très désagréable qui peut pas
pousser son plan b après tour à dire
d'accord on croise suite paraît
peut-être six mois je suis tu es là
cavalier e 2 c'est une manoeuvre manaf
de cavalli oui c'est peut-être le seul
coup sur lesquels on peut un petit peu
on peut un petit peu comment dire
douter mais disons quand j'ai joué
cavalier 2 c'était vraiment pour éviter
b6 est sur mais bon je vous laisse
peut-être la possibilité de jouer six
essayer de se dégager par m6 auquel cas
j'aurais probablement ramener mon fond
h4 donc il aurait peut-être pu prouver
du contrô le à ce moment-là mal encadré
f6 flash 4 et la position possible et à
ce moment là on peut dire qu'il a
vraiment fait des fautes qui sont qui
sont des très graves erreurs après après
cavaliers de méaulte cavaliers 2 tu
pouvais pas essayer de le mettre en
quatre pour reprendre la case des six
une fois que tu avais changer si par
exemple cabello 4f six médailles aux 4b
6 me faisait peur ab système faisait
perdre accord et le problème c'est que
le fou en f3 de tapenade la puissance et
si c'est évidemment et il faut calculer
cédé 6 oui peut-être mais c'est
dangereux
tu peux peut-être cavaliers aux 4b 6
bouger la dame simplement peut-être
prendre ces cinq avec lecavalier
c'est donc c'est l'idée de se mettre ce
qu'allait donc en 2 donc tu veux tu veut
positionner ou ce cavalier sur la case
f4 se rassemble pour l'instant j'attends
j'attends de voir ce qui sa réaction
j'attends de 20,6 ils essayent de
pousser ses pions et c'est de chasser
monfront g5 ou le cavalier e 2 peuvent
rebondir sur f4 il peut revenir sur ces
trois bons c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur coup mais ans donc ça cet
attentat c'est un coût d'attenté dans
une position quand même assez con dire
assez fort assez forte
alors h6 alors là ça pose la question
aux fous donc ça va lui permettre de des
clous et se plie en deux sets
oui il a des clous et son pur le set
mais malheureusement c'est la grosse
faute de la partie
h6 suivi est suivie de jessica lange et
5 alors ça c'est toujours c'est toujours
sujet à caution ce genre de coups
puisque ont affaibli son rock c'est ça
oui donc on peut dire que la grande
leçon de cette partie c'est c'est tout
simplement le faiblissement
l'affaiblissement du rock
voilà on voit la loire ou l'ain jeu nous
a montré avec les cases on voit que les
cases g6 ch 721 sont beaucoup plus
faibles puisque le pion les pions sont
soucaze noir ne protège plus ces cases
et donc c'est une possibilité surtout
que le fou de cases blanches est
toujours aux mains des blancs donc ce
fou va pouvoir contrôler cette belle
diagonale
oui là quand on va juste coucher ça
qu'on peut dire qu'on adversaire était
vraiment pas au meilleur de sa forme
parce que c'est vraiment un très très
mauvais coup c'est inconscient parce
qu'il donne toutes les cases blanches
alors qu'il a plus de foule blanc pour
les contrôler donc mon fou j'ai trois
jeux enfin je le repas se font g3
toujours avec quelques idées sur cette
grande diagonale aussi la gamme
diagonale h2v huit mois parce que là tu
tapes à la fois sur le cavalier ans et 7
et ils à tours en b 8 ou est toujours
des possibilités pour pour activer
activé c'est fou voilà donc là aussi ça
bloque les possibilités de pousser de
pian du plan et 56 oui quand il joue
aussi s'il veut installer un cavalier en
d5 tout simplement et essayer de se
dégager un petit peu en tout cas essayer
d'installer un avant poste
et là j'ai joué un coup un très bon coup
là dans cette position c'est que je
reviens donc je reviens à n'ont pas tout
de suite je joue d'abord alors là c'est
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure 24 en cas
de contrôle la belle diagonale et on
peut imaginer des manoeuvres dont je
connais pas la suite de la partie mais
j'ai gardé ma vient d'ailleurs de dames
ces deux menaces m'attend h7 et keller
difficile a par ailleurs oui tout
simplement donc là il l'a trouvé la
parade pour pour cette menace d'un bus
est donc d'amener cette fougue et un fou
bien donc là l'a menacé d'un des trois
avec camatte
à venir qu'à l'air difficile à paris un
tour eiffe des huit avec cavaliers fuite
qui contrôlerait donc la case h7 voilà
donc il va le cavaly revient soit cassé
3 je reviens sera cassé trois tout
simplement dans l'idée de venir henri iv
est un des six cavaliers sur quand je
vois aussi si secret aussi il s'est créé
une case forte en d5 mais s'est créé une
belle casse faible aussi en d6 c'est ça
exactement donc l'avantagé inconvénients
il n'avait pas trop le choix avec le
flanc j'ai trois cavaliers fui l'enclavé
fuite ça c'est pour empêcher les
manoeuvres de maths puisqu'une temps le
qualifie d' protège de la case h7 est là
cavalier ou 4 je crois même que la mort
la suite voilà cavalli ou 4 et ce
cavalier va venir sont encore indécises
israël sera superbe ce cavalier il sera
un très très bon avant postes pour
lecavalier ont surtout qu'il est soutenu
par les deux pions le fou g3 est il donc
il va il va permettre l'atteinte du
point
cet été il va provoquer en tout cas d
affaiblissement
supplémentaires dans le roc noir on va
voir la suite en cavale et d510 pas son
cavalier sur la casamance est hélas
qu'avec des si c'est la réponse alors on
voit quand même que la casse des cinq
qui est forte pour le nord est quand
même dans le camp noir puisque fait
partie des quatre ans j'ai qu'on peut
estimer qu'ils font partie du camp noir
alors que la casse des six elle est bien
au delà du camp blanc est bien un bien
dans le camp adverse
donc le cas le cas liens des six est
beaucoup plus fort que le comédien
desseigne donc il y les forces et plus
ou moins d'essayer d'un petit peu
d'éliminer mon centre dont qui jouait
pts 5
donc je prends en passant donc ça c'est
la prise en passant il faut rappeler
donc un lampion bouche de deux cases
effectivement on peut prendre sur la
case la première case du pion et faire
disparaître les pions comme ça c'est un
des rares qu aux échecs qu'ils soient un
peu curieux mais qui permet comme ça d'
éliminer les pions qui veulent aller
trop vite donc dans cette position là je
j'ai joué un petit peu par impulsion on
peut dire donc j'ai accumulé un avantage
positionnelle un placement de pièces qui
est énorme et j'ai pensé que je pouvais
faire quelque chose d'un petit peu jolie
donc j'ai sacrifié une pièce dans cette
position ah voilà donc là un sacrifice à
la sacem importants de la partie puisque
la tour f1 se sacrifie contre le fu ans
et fils alors on peut dire que c'était
quand même le fou protéger les cases
noires du code du camp noir et
maintenant et on fout g3 va devenir très
fort c'est ça exactement mon fou g3
devenir très fort le foot est un jeu
vous déjà énormément le bon une deux
tours sur la colonne f ça change pas
beaucoup
je veux je pense que les foules vont
vraiment faire la différence de cette
position alors surtout qu'on peut pas
jouer dame prend tour puisqu'il y aurait
fou au 5e tour et la dame exactement
donc d'un grand tour qui perd la dame
immédiatement il doit prendre la tour en
m6 avec lecavalier
voilà donc les lois nous montre
parfaitement le clouage qui suivit un ce
qui surviendrait et donc la vallée pour
ainsi s'efforcer et maintenant touré fin
donc qui menace tout reprend f6 à
nouveau au quel cas donc sur d'un bref
si je gagnerai la dame parfois et c'est
tout simplement tout à fait donc là
cavalier 17 protège le cavalier f6 et là
j'ai fait un coup qui a été assez
difficile à trouver qui est très très
très dangereux qui fait très mal
c'est dans sa position bon il a encore
quelques chances pour tenir la position
si je joue faux 5
mais là je fais un come back c'est à
dire je reviens en c4 avec lecavalier
venir aux 5 pour venir angers 6 faire
une fourchette entre le roi à schwyz et
la dame et la dame cet homme au fond
j'ai trois attaques la tour en b 8
mais bon j'ai pas vraiment l'attention
de l'apprendre puisque je contrôle
toutes les cases noires donc c'est fou
on peut dire oui dans il est fou ce sens
beaucoup plus fort que les tours dans
cette position d'accord ça c'est
important ça veut dire que la valeur des
pièces qu'on signale toujours une pour
vous cinq points ou 3 points suivants la
position ça peut complètement s'inverser
on peut dire que comme c'est une
position d' attaque il faut relativiser
il faut surtout vous pensez donc à
d'autres facteurs donc le facteur
important dans cette position c'est
surtout les pions h6 g5 qui sont trop
avancé et qui ne protège pas du tout le
roi et donc
donc les fous dans cette position
peuvent vraiment bien intervenir sur le
roi ici en fait le plan des blancs c'est
d'échanger une paire de cavaliers
puisque après on pourra plus tenir nos
surtout de cavaillon f6 qu'on est
probablement le tout la défense du roi
donc après les changes
enfin après qu'elliot 5 qui va changer
d'os cavaliers ça va être très très
difficile pour les n'aura peut-être tu
sais quand tu disais justement que la
valeur des pièces était relative je
crois qu'il faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que les tours ont besoin de
colonnes les fous de diagonale et les
cavaliers de cases un conte fonction de
leurs déplacements et dans cette
position les leaf ou blancs ont des
diagonales absolument magnifique et les
tours noir n'ont pas de colonne tout
simplement toutes les colonnes sont
fermés à part la colonne f et la colonne
des fonds peut pas voir marié venir avec
tout les fourchettes un g6 ou ou food et
6 même si la tournée à 9,8 oui la
limande dam tour donc en fait c'est pour
ça que les fous sont beaucoup plus forts
c'est parce qu'ils ont des diagonales et
les kabyles sont très forts aussi
fallait cavalier blanc à cause des pneus
est très fort parce qu'il a beaucoup de
cases à nos cinq ans j'ai 6 ans des six
des classes forte c'est pour ça qu'en
fait donc ça dépend vraiment infections
du caractère de la position fictivement
plus les colonnes sont ouverts tous les
tours sont fortes et puis plus ça reste
une exception tonnellerie c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que c'est quand même un grand
principe de base
il faut très bien alors on va suivre
alors qu'à relier des cinq maintenant
hélas jean-luc dont on suppose juste
pause voilà me lecavalier sur la case 5
dans l'idée c'est d'échanger une paire
de cavaliers et de fer fourchette avant
tout est de faire fourchette la menace
fourchette attention car les g6 échec au
roi gagnate aux dames 7h faire attention
à ça il fourchette à angers 6 une
fourchette en f7 enfin de pas beaucoup
de force oui parce que la tour eiffe un
protège la case fc est aussi donc il ya
beaucoup de beaux coups de fourchettes
possibles pile élimine une des rares
pièces de défense en fait il n'y aura
plus aucune pièce pour défendre le roi
une fois qu'il aura échanger et ramener
son x 2,5 donc il est obligé quasiment
de prendre le cavalier oui et là
maintenant fou prend je suppose échec
et là on voit que le roi est vraiment
tout seul tout seul et ça va être dur
pour lui parce que là ils les deux fous
sont vraiment braqué dessus tout les cas
ce prêt du roi sont contrôlés par les
blancs est donc le dernier petit coup
donc un petit coup de dames qui et qui
le force à abandonner puisque je menace
tout simplement d'alger 6 et le roi n'a
pas de case il doit donner la dame
la seule défense sur dame c2c cavaliers
des 5 f 4 et là bon
j'ai pas vraiment calculé je pense que
j'ai 3 par exemple est suffisant j'ai
trois simplement attaque le cavalier et
si il bouge il ya un math forcé à
mathilde donné le cavalier et puis il y
aura toujours les mêmes menaces après
donc ici par le cavalier non seulement
il a hélas perdu l'avantagé matériel la
fin théorique parce qu'il avait la
qualité donc ça s'était terminé si les
blancs qui ont l'avantagé de la table
continue exactement où j'ai même un
sacrifice de qualité en f4 si si on veut
continuer à sacrifier des pièces mais je
pense que j'aurais joué j'ai 3 je pense
que c'est le coup le plus sage dans
cette position oui il n'ya plus
tranquille qu'on est d'accord donc hélas
est donc là il abandonne la surnomment
ses deux donc il abandonne la position
est sans espoir
donc là c'est donc c'est une victoire
très importante il était invité à
égalité c'est ça j'ai trouvé qu'il avait
un demi point de moins
mais bon il n'était pas loin et c'était
quand même un des adversaires les plus
dangereux qui et qui sont donc en tête
de l'accession voilà donc très belles
parties de jean-luc chavanon commenté
avec avec david marciano alors david
martial il reste combien normes
nationales et une rente pour nous est de
port e et 2 e ronde pour le
pour l'accession c'est à dire qu'ils
nous rendent dimanche aussi c'est ça oui
donc nous on a on allait donc le
désavantage de jouer la dernière partie
le matin à 9 heures du matin
oui donc donc le tournoi qui a été assez
physique continue donc le spectacle va
continuer ça va être très très chaud
cette dernière partie puisqu'on va jouer
les qualifications donc quand tu vas
jouer slim belkhodja c'est sûr donc
demain je vais je vais jouer
belkhodja puisqu'on on est tous les deux
en tête je suis premier il est deuxième
et on s'est pas rencontrés
donc je vais le jouer je ne sais pas
avec quelle couleur à tout à l'heure et
après demain donc j'aurai peut-être
salle ainsi s'ils gagnent mais bon donc
moi mon objectif actuellement c'est
plutôt de conserver la première place en
faisant peut-être un point sur deux donc
2 nul pourrait suffire c'est terminé
donc oui avec deux matches nuls ce qui
serait ce qui serait très très bien pour
pour assurer la première place
lorsque c'est facile comme ça de celles
assurées les nuls sur le fait on dit
souvent que pour faire nul il faut aussi
de gagner c'est jamais facile aux échecs
1 de toute façon si on veut trop faire
nul on finit par perdre c'est un nom oui
oui mais bon
l'adversaire aussi a également le même
problème donc toute façon moi je joue la
partie et puis on voit on voit toute
façon ce genre de tournoi se joue l
énergie et donc à l'énergie est aussi à
la force la force dans le tournoi la
forme des joueurs
on va par l'énergie je t'aime avec david
lynch quelques minutes tu analyses
nationales de l'intérieur donc là
etienne bacrot fait un parcours
fantastique
il est suivi maintenant part je crois
cependant un ex entraîneur est aussi
dorfman mais à un point mais qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire que etienne bacrot a
plus d'énergie que les autres joueurs je
crois qu'il est fort tout simplement
plus d'énergie je sais pas donc c'est
pas sûr enfin bon disons qu'il ya de
tout dans le national il ya des joueurs
qui sont très sérieux très travailleur
très sportif ya des joueurs qui sont
plus fêtards donc effectivement le
joueur qui a un rythme de vie sain comme
bonjour je connais pas tellement etienne
sur ce point là mais bon c'est un jeune
joueur qui sort pas donc je suppose
qu'il se fatigue pas pendant le tournoi
je connais pourquoi nietzsche par
exemple qu'un exemple d'énergie qu'un
joueur lorsque les autres joueurs
sortent trop il ya tout j'en connais qui
sortent et j'en connais qui sont très
sérieux donc en général en fin de
tournoi c'est vrai que c'est plus facile
pour ceux qui se couchent tôt mais
mais bon il par exemple je connais darko
nietzsche qui est un modèle d'énergie
cement qui qui qui n'est pas un joueur
exceptionnel bien qu'il ait des qualités
importantes stratégiques notamment mais
qui est toujours en pleine forme pendant
un tournoi et qui fait toujours des très
bons nationaux parce qu'il arrive bien
reposé en forme qui fait très attention
lorsque ça veut dire qu'un joueur
d'échec quand je pose la question aux
deux parce que là ça veut dire qu'un
joueur d'échecs donc pour maintenir son
énergie ce qu'au bout d'un tournoi qui
est long comme ça sur lequel il faut se
tenir sur la durée doit aussi faire une
activité physique pour se maintenir en
forme et pas craqué sur la fin je pense
que c'est mieux en théorie en pratique
moi le premier je suis pas toujours très
assidus mais mais je pense que c'est
mieux maintenant sur chacun aussi et son
rythme de vie je crois qu'il faut le
respecter il ya des gens qui sont nés
pour se lever tôt et des gens qui sont
nés pour pour se lever un peu plus tard
enfin je pense vraiment que c'est même
ça remonte à loin de ces on le voit à
l'école les gens qui ont du mal à se
lever le matin et ceux qui n'ont pas
quoi est symptomatique oui don de vie
d'un peu près raison mais disons que
faut voir quand même que quand on joue
de trois partis qui font six ou huit
heures de jeu il faut être capable de
récupérer
donc c'est
tout le monde n'a pas la même
récupération je pense que c'est quand
même mieux d'avoir une activité physique
fin quand on fait des échecs
professionnellement j'entends oui pour
vraiment ou alors ou alors faut changer
son style faut attaquer très très vite
fo est très agressif pour terminer la
partie vite mais je crois que kasparov
qui modèlent d'énergie je crois en effet
beaucoup beaucoup le sport il ya il dit
qu'il fait du fait du footing il fait il
fait du bateau il fait bon être un très
haut niveau c'est c'est tout à fait
compatible je pense que c'est même
nécessaire d'avoir une activité physique
et c'est pas le seul il ya des joueurs
comme topalov qui le grand maître
topalov le bulgare qui sont qui sont
très très bonne condition physique
d'accord donc voilà sur ce monde là mais
je crois qu'on va maintenant passer la
main à eluard lange qui va accueillir y
oscille dorfman qui a fait une
excellente partie aujourd'hui qu'ils se
positionnent peut-être pour le titre
puisqu'il doit maintenant rencontrer
etienne bacrot demain il a un point de
retard et le
le leader du national féminin où la
leader c'est pourquoi on peut dire marie
sebha qui a à peine 15 ans et qui fait
un parcours remarquable
et voilà il va vous présenter ces deux
joueurs tout de suite voilà je passe la
parole à eloi merci stéphane donc david
et jean luc je vais vous inviter à
quitter plateau fils qu'il n'a que trois
places malheureusement donc voilà je
vais accueillir notre nouveau invité
idiot si je dors fans qu'on a déjà reçu
donc champion de france 98 mary bale et
marie se bague qui va également venir me
rejoindre sur ce plateau et installez
vous alors
donc on va commencer honneur aux filles
évidemment puisque donc la galanterie
nous y nous le propose donc marie tu es
en tête du national féminin alors que tu
n'as que alors par le plus près du micro
14 ans et ce à 14 ans et là tu viens de
gagner une partie donc très importante
mais c'est d'ailleurs c'est à dire entre
passé à tuer patuc obstacles de la hier
et aujourd'hui qu'ils ont encore gagné
ouais voilà donc tu te retrouves avec
si je dis pas de bêtises sept mois et
demi ouais sur neuf et ta poursuivante
directe c'est marina costagliola qui
avait commencé avec 7 sur 7 et qu'il
reste à 7 sur 7
il ya muller aussi abjecte donc qui
elles sont deux à te poursuivre mais bon
alors donc c'est en fait ce qui nous
intéresse qui nous tourmentent le plus
c'est comment est ce que c'est possible
à 14 ans d'être en tête du championnat
de france toutes catégories alors un
talent particulier beaucoup
d'entraînements tu t'entraînes beaucoup
bas un peu une à deux heures par jour ce
n'est pas une ou deux heures par jour
ouais heineken va appuyer quelquefois
pas du tout quelquefois pas du tout
c'est un entraîneur attitré
ouais j'ai pascal chaullet pascal
chaumeil qui joue dans l'axé son jeu
monde d'accord et donc tout ça ça marche
ça marche très bien puisque ça fait une
bonne méthode une bonne formule en tête
demain tu joues contre marina roumégous
way avec les pièces noires bah ouais
d'accord donc ton objectif de comment
est-ce que tu abordes cette fin de
tournoi thaddée faire nul tu veux jouer
pour le gain toutes les parties tu veux
gérer le tournoi j'aimerais bien gagner
mais vous d'accord donc tu veux gagner
toutes les parties tu veux gagner le
tournoi tout simplement bah tu penses
que ça va être possible chez pas hélas
partie quoi bon alors on va demander un
avis un avis d'expert donc ceci le
dorfman ex en trois ans de kasparov on
ne le redira jamais assez puisque c'est
quand même une sacrée référence choc en
france 98 qu'est ce que tu penses de
mari ce baquet du national féminin en
général
c'est difficile je n'ai pas prêté que
moi c'est la chambre le championnat
féminin je les garde évidemment les
résultats mais je n'ai pas vu les
résultats d'aujourd'hui si j'ai bien
compris qu stable à l'aller perdu contre
mieux leur nom oui c'est ça la peur de
parties de suite elle donc 709 adacore
donc y met les caussignols et elles sont
sur sept points toutes les données
oui oh oui mais c'est intéressant
maintenant mais déjà que tu m'avais mène
le championnat c'est extraordinaire
parce que j'ai jamais vu le championnat
de france féminin aussi fort que cette
année il y trois juristes comme les
comptes de rose
telle demande est costaud on rentre
renforcer énormément le championnat et
ça devient du plu aux blues
professionnels ici elle est en gros tu
gagnes c'est un grand succès bien sûr
oui mais je n'ai pas regardé les paras
team du mari des pays
un bon moment parce qu'avant mon allée
cette fille ariane qu il l a joué
souvent contre marie j'étais obligé de
regarder c'est parti bien sûr qu'elle
dans la préparation mais cette année je
n'ai pas donc j'ai rien à dire
franchement donc docile dorfman s'est
préparée contre toi ça te en effet
particulier mais je crois que tu es
obligée peut-être quelque chose
d'important c'est que marie est
championne de france chez les garçons
entre guillemets oui j'en prenne au vent
sur les garçons au moins de 14 ans cette
année d'accord donc alors oui alors ça
c'est vrai que c'est très important
puisque c'est la première fois en france
qu'une fille gagne un championnat mx que
je joue je crois pas qu'ils aient
d'autres
autre exemple est tout à fait mais de
toute façon pour gagner un championnat
qu'il faut déjà penser à jouer dans ce
cas pas évident puisqu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de filles qui l'ont fait donc
en tout cas bravo bravo marie ça c'est
ça s'est très très bien alors on va
peut-être passer au national masculin
d'abord un petit mot marine qu'est ce
que tu penses de tous ses joueurs d'un
favori pour le tournoi mais je vais
boire mais maintenant ça va être dur
ouais bon une attaque
bon alors c'est des joueurs préférés en
tout cas des joueurs forfaits de marie
iossif aujourd'hui tu aies gagné une
très très belle partie non c'est pas une
très belle partie
je pense que mon adversaire elle était
un petit peu trop optimistes et
agressive et le mal jugé la pollution et
les âges et les premiers quinze coups
comme
comme kasparov top niveau mais après les
exagérer ses chances mais elle était
très très subtil des collabos je connais
donc de toutes façons c'est la partie
qu'on va regarder tout à l'heure donc au
pouvoir la commenter ensemble
maintenant on va peut-être commenté un
peu le classement puisque etienne bacrot
à gagner surtout donc en tête avec 7
points et demi tu es en deuxième
position si je ne fais pas d'erreur avec
six et demi ex-aequo avec
je vais pas ex-aequo donc voilà donc on
a les deux plus forts classement c'était
etienne bacrot et toi qu'ils sont en
tête
et demain tu as un point de moins et des
couleurs noir contre tu joues contre
etienne bacrot donc qu'est-ce que tirage
au sort pas forcément favoris
non je ne crois pas que la couleur joue
certes un rôle à mon avis aucun même pas
d'heure plus tôt je préférerais nous
d'accord saperaient les intérêts mais je
pense sincèrement ce qu'elle et son
répertoire est très équilibré avec les
noirs ni aussi pour moi c'est absolument
pas réussi si tu as regardé mes parties
j'avais à chaque fois les chances avec
le noir avec la blonde pas toujours mais
nous avons chaque partie sauf la partie
comme des rachats aussi dorfman la jouer
pour le gain ou île où il va se
contenter d'être vice-champion de france
ça je peux faire tout de suite pour être
les champions de france
ici il suffit de passer un coup de fil
qu'est ce que je peux perdre demain donc
ça ça veut dire que c'est possible
allait proposer nul éventuellement avant
la partie c'est une pratique qui se fait
donc pour poser du labo est évidemment
mais de toute façon peut proposer
pendant puisque bien entendu etienne
bacrot mais les blancs ne va prenant pas
forcé dans cette partie ne va pas
prendre de risque a priori puisqu'une
nul lui suffit pour être champion de
france
donc en fait c'est un nouveau challenge
puisque gagner avec les noirs c'est
quand même pas la chose la plus facile à
faire
oui bien sûr donc devant une très grosse
partie on verra on va essayer tous les
douze croix d'accord et bien donc une
belle partie à voir demain de toute
façon on vous la commentera demain
puisque ça va être la partie explosive à
venir alors là on va peut-être commencer
à passer aux commentaires partie si la
partie est prête on va on va commenter
la partie de yo silverman aujourd'hui
contre eux jean-marc degraeve donc tu
avais les blancs et une fois de plus tu
as joué contre un système
indien veut dire on vide mais j'ai mal
peut-être deviné qu'elle est vertueux et
la préparer parce que lille p j'ai
pratiquement tout jean marc c'est un
joueur agressif avec beaucoup
d'imagination
donc il est un petit peu peut-être plus
large
son répertoire est un peu plus large que
celle gorna taf mais ils jouent à peu
près dans le même esprit les cours
toujours très actif et cherche les gants
et j'ai envisagé des mots ni l'east
india vient de kagame est grande pour
imaginer la préparation donc il fallait
donc je prie pour la base certaines
vertus au jeu tout préparé très
profondément pour le reste il fallait
éviter le reste donc elle est de l'ordre
du cou qui me permet et je fais le fasse
avant la partie pour choisir donc
peut-être j'ai mal choisi aujourd'hui de
résultats bons mais pour le vertueux je
ne serais pas content d'accord donc en
fait jean marc degraeve que jouer
diverses ouvertures et tu cherchais lui
en enlever certaines vont permettre d'
autres et tu as fini par choisir le
groupe - qui avait bien je pense que les
premiers clac son coût explique pour
monte pour lesquels ouverture j'ai
rejoué c'est évident j'ai eu 4 c'est
surprenant puisque tu perds mais
peut-être c'est ça je ne sais pas est-ce
que c'est transposerait dans une
sicilienne
je manque quelques jeux marc aussi il
joue ça mais j'aime beaucoup marré c'est
avec les bains d'ailleurs vous analyser
ensemble je crois avec tôt rabin il y à
une époque et il ya le jeu garde
toujours cette analogie que j'ai utilisé
contre s'évalue à torino
oui donc vous voyez je jouais c4 à la
maison de jeunes visages à cet ordre du
coup et je me suis dit que je vais faire
ces trois plutôt qu'aux majeurs
contrairement à l'année dernière
une position agréable pour les blancs
mais elle est difficile à gagner
alors l'idée de ces trois c'est
évidemment de neutraliser l'action du
fou g7 et surtout contre un joueur qui
aime beaucoup attaqué la case des cadres
et les casses noir ça je connais mais
peut-être j'étais un petit peu
émotionnel aussi puisque normalement à
la maison j'ai décidé de jouer ces trois
faux des trois petits roquets donc
quelque chose de plus un peu plus solide
dans le projet moins ambitieux puisque
ces quatre ça comme l'air d'être le coup
comme on le sent ici après fo g4 que
faire elle attaque la casse des quatre
et ça il faut vous en ai déjà la
structure du point de prendre cher
donc quand je fais ces quatre je
préparais déjà des cadres des cinq
autrement je perde le contrôle de la
casse des cadeaux alors pourquoi ce
choix
on dit souvent qu'il faut pas avancer
ses pions trop vite dans l'ouverture
puisque ça donne
enfin ça donne l'opportunité aux noirs
de jouer c7 c6 et s'éprend des cinq très
vite ça leur prend pas beaucoup de temps
d'aller chercher des pions puisqu'ils
sont déjà arrivés tout seul vous savez
le prises 71 5 to soul est absolument
offensive parce que je peux prendre
donne les conditions propices aux grands
desseins qui attaquaient lui en aurait
on eu 7
donc il doit bien choisir il a trouvé
les moyens
malheureusement pour moi elle a trouvé
les moyens comment un péché je prends
des sacs et après ce petit jeu donc des
raisons non mais ici oui j'ai fait faux
bond mais peut-être acheté aurait été
plus précis nous ici de faire le comité
encore la partie bien sûr damas est
pourquoi je cavale et s'est trouvé ces
jeux font des dons il y as d'un v6 et
après cavaliers se trouvait il mange des
pions paix dr ben adama troyes et tours
b3g récupère le puits on peut être un
pcet mais je n'ai pas vu aucun avantage
là bas donc il faut faire peut-être que
kebede de dès que le risque est déjà
pauvres oui tout à fait c'est un
développement naturel évidemment alors
ici cavaignac 6 l à ton avis sur la
position c égalité les noirs sont
proches de l'égalité il était
confortable de dire déjà peut-être une
légère ni ceinture noire 1 pour les
noirs décor bien sûr faut faire
attention avec les blancs parce que
c'est qu'ils piquent les noirs attaque
c'est comme dans l'aveyron de listing
avec g3 souvent les noirs a taclé la
dame blanche il ya les difficultés pour
achever les deux donc j'ai fait tourner
bien avec les dj pk tu fu béton mais
j'ai remarqué les anticipent ils jouent
dans ces sept voiliers avant bekkat oui
donc on va passer encore au barracuda fc
sète
oui je donne comme c'est maintenant aux
bécanes à mon avis c'est une faute grave
tout simplement je n'ai pas vraiment
comment ils répètent à temps à cause de
ou à cause de certaines choses
mon idée je pensais que les finales les
finales peuvent devenir très gênant a
précédé ceux des dom seydoux voyez donc
j'ai préféré avoir son cavalier en
assises d'abord et après laisser jouer
la finale mais commence à jouer le rôle
décisif dans cette partie h3 fou 17
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne prend pas on
est roi où ils disent que tout joueur
qui essaie de froid pour un f3 finale
avec la peur de rien du tout et plus
tard je peux j'ai tranquillement torrent
fouet d'houphouet faire revenir
conserver le contrôle de ducasse blanchi
les blondes au moins une belle position
et encore si vous prenez en f3 faut
prendre trois
le cours suivant déjà cédé cbcb qatar
vous comprenez ça marche aussi très
désagréable ici après faut prendre à
vous prenez un dessin qu'il y a un grand
dessein que j'attaque le piano cède donc
elle peut pas prendre part à des camps
non mais là j'avoue que c'était un peu
le comprendrait bien apprécié le jeu est
maintenant je ne vois pas comment
tourner mes pièces sur b4 d'autres d3 d4
donc il faut faire b3 et maintenant il
est bien de jouer donc avant petro a
super j'aimerais bien expliquer une
chose c'est très important de 15 jours
b3 je perds deux déjà toutes les espoirs
chercher un avantage en ouverture
normalement pour essayer de jouer encore
davantage il fallait faire faut des
trois essais le cookie j'ai préparé mais
je me suis dit aujourd'hui on regarde on
les parties du jeune marquis l'extrême
font avec un avantage de développement
se sont rués
oui ça c'est clair qu'il ya eu
énormément parti comme ça voilà donc fou
des trois peut-être pourquoi fo détroit
s'il prend le pire encore en beta donc
faute et roissy prend en d5 je peux
prendre le banc des cinq mois j'ai
étudié les variantes avec b5 et je me
suis dit que c'est trop un petit peu 3
mai coridon qui en fait il arrive à
casser le cas c'est un peu la structure
directement facile et beaucoup
d'initiatives pour les noirs s'il faut
être j'aime pas cette pollution
oui tu voulais absolument pas lui donner
une chance d'avoir l'initiative il
fallait calmer le jeu au plus vite ici
aussi ils ouvrirent la colonne
il a final s'avère peut-être beaucoup
plus précisément donc c'est prend d ela
donc tu est forcé de reprendre avec
l'option c'est sinon surprend il ya
faute d'accord donc là une variante
simple on va là on va là l'indiqué fou
et cinq attaques la tour b 1
la tour doit aller sur la case 1 ou b2
et se met donc dans le feu du fou g7
ce qui est une catastrophe puisque le
kali arrivant au caté c3 donc ici c'est
totalement impossible donc en fait les
blancs sont forcés de faire une
concession puisqu'ils reprennent pas de
la façon naturelle dans la partie il ya
eu la reprise s'éprend des cinq que les
blancs n'avaient pas envie de faire mais
n'oubliez pas que le cavalier c'est le
seul désavantage des noirs ici le
malaise développer la pièce
confortablement par fodé trois ep 4 fo
métaux ça peut devenir désagréable après
cavaliers des cadres donc les noix les
noix je souligne georges et
dynamiquement malgré tout projet
dynamiquement malgré une belle position
on peut pas envisager à 5 eca média 6 a
précisément parce que je vais peut-être
réussir d'obtenir cette personne avec
fous des trois quarts les six taureaux
et se retourner ça sent quand même le
four revient en f1 mais vous n'avez pas
du final et après faut pas tout car ça
devient statique des cordons cavalia 6
très très dynamique
ici l'idée évidemment de devenir en ce
sens que je présume rats exclusion
pourquoi cavaliers 6 avant le tournoi il
peut faire danser de immédiatement c'est
encore un moment très importante et peut
faire et c'est dans cette directive il
est réfléchi en euros mois et demi
corinne peinaud aussi presque sûr dans
des taudis où j'avais poussé 4 gagne du
temps et s'il prend on dénature 31 il
vous revient tranquillement en effet il
a gagné le tour mais le fait d'abord car
elle est assise sur tora dans celle de
maintenant au fossé 4 c'est débile je
perds de tout simplement pour comprendre
oui tout à fait vrai subtil jusqu'au
bout ici c'est une finesse de plus oui
tout à fait en tout cas les a6 et n'ont
pas d'âme ses deux pour le jouer pour
fait que les blancs ne dispose pas de
mot est-il donc je vous tourner
maintenant on fait dame ces deux là
l'idée donc en fait c'est un gain de
gain de temps
alors là sur évidemment poussé quatre
c'est la même variante avec le canadien
en a six qui n'est pas
une bonne chose dame prend ses deux
tours procès deux fous d1 alors là
toutes les pièces sur la première rangée
léger jeff haut des seins parce que si
je joue au foot est roi il y à tour ses
droits mais à part ça il faut comme tu
es surtout à 12 je ne peux pas chasser
la tour tandis qu'avec le fundi
autoradio il y avait 4 ans menace en
fait trop à cette très importante
d'accord donc ici en fait on peut jouer
pour enfermer la tour des noirs la pièce
active en fait des noirs four b3 attaque
la torah 2 qui n'a plus de 15 ou en tout
cas qui devra wii qui devra aller
peut-être lassé changé sur la case 1 en
tout cas le fou en d1 est bien placé
pour chasser cette tour en a deux donc
ici ses tours ses 7 qui a été joué en
retrait de laisser le club joue b4 et
maintenant le camion à six est mal placé
mais ici moi enfin mon analyse pendant
la partie puisque j'avais suivi après
avoir fait une houle assez rapidement
contre manuel a pissé là j'ai suivi
cette partie est mon analyse était que
les blancs étaient déjà problème mieux
puisque je vous dis absolument aucun
chemin pour améliorer ce qu'elle va dire
massif et donc ont joué certaines pièces
de moi je pense que les noirs n'arrive à
rien si si si ils sont réalistes encore
il fallait changer si je suis d'accord
c'est le meilleur coup parce que
malheureusement pour les blancs je ne
peux pas je ne peux pas jouer en attaque
où à part de fouet doute parce que les
menaces faut des 3 et surtout b3 le
gâteau de pousser un cri ambriz oui ici
excusez moi ici je joue ici le couple
s'était fourré de 15 qui étaient obèses
nous laissions il y à il est à la
combinaison et la préparer foot est roi
foot est roi et surtour bougies léa
cavaliers prend 1,4 oui et quand je
prends je sais que quand il prend des
tons intermédiaire
d'accord c'est pour ça qu'elle avait
l'étoffé france est vide et il est
revenu on sait cette avec la tour pour
défendre l'option hausse est également
voir membres de blé tout est ici ce qui
permet donc et cette petite combinaison
de marché qui empêche le développement
normal du phocéen sur la case b2 et donc
ça affaiblit encore les cases blanches
mans après les changes des fous c'est si
on revient à la partie après fou 2 vous
prend tout reprendre la case d3
peut-être
lee jusqu'à ce moment il était très
dynamique tout était bon mais s'ils
perdent le chinois je crois ici il rate
quelque chose donc est évidemment qu'il
n'est pas qu'à valider de betoya il
arrête à cette manière je crois et la
pression d'un commencé à dégrader
donc ça déjà c'est absolument inutile
s'il n'y a pas si on parle encore
réaliste au lieu tôt ces sept on peut
faire tous ces échanges et encore faut
il faire avec la menace car la b5 et
connaît ses 3 donc si on jours pour
obtenir une position normale
on ne va la voir son problème il fallait
jouer simplement tort assez vite et
ensuite après foulée de échangé avec
maman j'ai dit avant quand j'ai attaqué
la tolérance et de il fallait faire
peut-être tôt c'est si vite après les
changes du fou voilà d'accord donc ici
par contre dans cette position là qu'est
ce qui
oui si déjà c'est un petit peu compliqué
parce que si l'auto à ces dj fo bedo
avec les dés de la pression oui donc
dans cette position déjà c'est pas si
facile forcément pour les noirs ce qu'on
a plus de pompiers on n'a plus de plan
pierre par exemple si vous faites cavale
et f6 17 exemple comme life 6,17 et
après faut pédaler change avec les
détours c3 puis j'ai pu espérer s'y
prendre longtemps
moi je pense que d'accord oui puisque
c'est vrai que les noirs sont vengés
c'est le chant qui sont la colonne s'est
déjà d'accord pour ces deux c'est une
grosse faute puisque là il y as
cavaliers t4 la tour vient on a deux
sinon c'est une perte de temps net donc
ici on continue et la fouille b2 donc
foulées de la tour se retrouve quand
même dans une position un peu à la danse
un peu tendancieuse elle est enfermée
effectivement le plan cavaliers d2 en p3
ensuite calé c1 qui ramassent la tour
donc dans cette position là ça a l'air
sévère déjà pas si facile de trouver des
plans de défense et en plus il était
déjà en gagnante et le cavalier à six
est toujours hors jeu donc ça devait ça
commence à faire beaucoup de facteurs
ont joué ou virtuellement avec une pièce
de moins pour les noirs et une tour
enfermé donc là ça commence
effectivement être très très chaud donc
les coûts tour c'est vite la qualité de
b3 très logique il nomine jose cobo
je travaille sur de l'humain je
regardais effectivement encore cette
position dans les gradins et tour c4
j'ai été très surpris puisque après tout
rien j'avais pas compris qu'elle est née
sa défense il a été vu c'est exactement
ce que je me disais puisqu'il était
envahie note c'est à dire qu'ils
n'avaient plus beaucoup de temps il
fallait qu'ils trouvent un coup dans
cette position s'était on peut revenir
prêter dans la position la tourette ans
et 8 voilà dans cette position-là la
menace ici et direct ces cavaliers c1
si je fais pas d'erreur même si je
connais pas ce qu'il ne bouge plus alors
est-ce qu'on peut pas envisager de jouer
15 et 17 dans cette position commune
peut-être donc ici ce serait à calais b
5 peut-être su recoller de cette menace
on a 7 et je protègerai après les
charges en vidéo je préfère le blanc il
y adeux les difficultés déjà sûr que les
sept tours c'est dodo jours donc on peut
dire qu'ici les noirs sont sous pression
comme avec d'autres
c'est très difficile donc ici la gaffe
est arrivé puisque tours c4 c'est la
faute des sisyphe vraisemblablement
puisque maintenant je tour c'est un très
bon coup pour prend tour et dont on
entoure perdre et à cause de cavalli
prend tour qui a enfermé la torah 2 donc
ça on le mentionne la torah de la
fameuse tour à 2 qui s'est un peu qui
s'aventuraient trop loin et est en prise
donc n'a plus de ne plus d'options donc
c'est injouable
on préfère jouer p5 tout reprend tour
maintenant b pro tour et maintenant
cavale et c'est un donc là je pense que
tu es tout calculé à ce moment là donc
toutes oreilles tout a été calculé
bien sûr pour prend b2 tour prend b2
cavani prendre quatre mais là il n'y a
plus d'espoir cavaliers c'est un e 2 et
là c'est terminé puisque à venir ses
tours ses deux on ramasse le plus haut
lac aux six autres manteaux cavada est
donc ici c'est un gain technique sur 3 6
3 au 6 e tour ces deux quand même des
cinq qui allait prendre 6 enfin la fin
se passe vraiment de commentaires et
quelques secondes donc ici marie
peut-être un commentaire sur cette
partie de düsseldorf man était belle
elle est technique des techniques de 33
coups quand même c'est une partie
relativement courte
33 pour l'âge du christ autrement je
pense avec eux son niveau jeu très bien
oui
alors est ce que tu es seulement est-ce
qu'une aussi de repas ne regrette pas
que macro et gagner aujourd'hui avec les
noirs contre corps parce qu'il
semblerait qu'il ait proposé nul tienne
macro agents en écho au 19e coup et
qu'il a une a refusé il a perdu c'est
dommage parce qu'ils savent être dur
pour demain pour gagner le titre alors
aux rectifications cpo 19e coup puisque
les noirs je pensais déjà mieux à ce
moment là c'est au neuvième coupe oui
c'est ça c'est au neuvième bout
c'est vraiment tout au début de la
partie mois seulement et toute façon
j'ai rien donc rappelons qu'en maison
jeu de la partie demain c'est etienne
bacrot blanc contrôle du secteur fans
etienne bacrot est leader avec un point
d'avancé donc de toutes façons possibles
devra gagner la partie pour être
champion de france 2000 nouveaux savez
diam's est le seul professionnel le seul
vrai professionnalisme innocence
moi je vais aucun projet sur ce tournoi
j'ai pris les décisions jeu dernier
moment et je pensais plutôt pour me
préparer un petit peu pour le tournoi
zonal je répète si les dix ans dans une
petite chance je suis tranquille le
résultat m'a intéressé par absolument
très détaché bon pas de pression pas de
pression mais enfin une grosse partie à
venir demain ça va être très intéressant
alors je ne sais pas si les invités
suivants sont arrivés ils sont là donc
de sylt hoffman merci beaucoup pour cet
encore cette analyse brillante mari
merci également donc vous êtes toujours
bienvenu sur le plateau des gones
je passais la parole de 30
or on
que je viens de faire ma troisième
normes de grand maître donc je vois que
tu suis avec intérêt les performances et
donc je vais avoir le titre au prochain
congrès vu que j'ai léger tournée
conditions j'ai rempli toutes les
conditions
c'est le prochain congrès qui a lieu
pendant les olympiades qui se déroule
début octobre
paquereau avec les blancs donc c'était
vraiment critique pour la suite de la
compétition et pour le titre alors tu as
joué avec panache puisque jeu il a
proposé nul au 9e coup et essayer de
gagner et mal mal mal tu en as pris
semble-t-il après la partie c'est plutôt
c'est plus facile de dire ce qu'il
fallait faire au début c'est vrai que
en gagnant j'avais pas mal de choses à
visée normes de lui remettre une chance
encore pour le titre donc
9e coup c'était début de la partie
c'était encore l'ouverture
donc c'est comme s'ils m'avaient proposé
nul avant de jouer dont j'estimais que
dans ma position faire nul à ce
moment-là présentait pas d'intérêt
d'accord donc c'était une partie tendue
je n'attaque velimir ont vite je crois
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé un petit
peu assez de partir à quel moment il a
pris l'avantagé tiennent donc tu as
perdu le fil je sais pas lequel des deux
j'ai joué un coup relativement
inhabituel qui est cavalier à 2 mais qui
a déjà été essayée sur quoi il a trouvé
je pense le meilleur coup devant
l'échiquier puisqu'il connaissait pas ce
qu'ils connaissaient pas ce coup et
après l'apposition blanche semble-t-il
est déjà un peu difficile
il a vu quelques chances pour moi par la
suite
par cavalier avec 5 au lieu de roye b 1
et c'est vrai que après roye b 1 toutes
ces pièces jouées c'est vraiment très
difficile pour moi
d'accord on en fait la partie se joue en
quelques coups comme c'est une ouverture
très tendu la moindre erreur ce mandat
erreurs se payent effectivement donc
c'est pendant ces quelques coups que la
partie s'est jouée probablement donc une
partie très très tendue en tout cas bon
mais c'est tout à ton honneur d'avoir
essayé de battre le petit comme on dit
en tout cas on aura peut-être l'occasion
d'ailleurs de voir peut-être la position
clé que tu as joué contre etienne mais
d'abord on va voir la partie qu'a livré
laurent frayssinet contre arnaud
hauchard lors laurent tu étais dans de
bonnes dispositions aujourd'hui la son
but il mais disons que j'ai j'ai fait
sur j'étais très bien portés dans le
tournoi j'avais 3 me sur 5 et j'ai fait
un demi sur les quatre dernières parties
donc ce qui est vraiment un score
lamentable et donc vu que j'ai plus
aucune chance de titre vu j'ai plus trop
rien espérer de ce tournoi j'ai
simplement j'avais simplement envie de
jouer aux échecs et de m'amuser donc
j'ai fait une partie s'est bien passé
mais bon disons que j'étais
j'étais assez détendu pour cette partie
on va voir tout de suite cette partie
vous allez voir que les ailes et très
spectaculaire en tout cas elle termine
en feu d'artifice donc laurent
frayssinet avec les blancs contre arnaud
hauchard avec les noirs alors arnaud
avait pas perdu une seule partie jusqu'à
celle là et il s'en allait
tranquillement vers un bon résultat dans
ce championnat
oui bien sûr mais disons que même même
cette défaite il ya une première journée
en championnat et donc disons que pour
lui aussi la vessie points donc un demi
point de retard sur etienne bacrot est
donc pour lui pour viser le titre c'est
vrai que c'était c'était mieux de me
battre et donc de prendre des risques et
surtout vu ma forme actuelle admis sur
quatre c'est vrai que il a eu raison de
tenter sa chance en tout cas donc il est
semble-t-il éliminé baisse et une sur il
éliminé de la course au titre
suite à cette partie donc on va voir
tout de suite donc lorente a choisi de
jouer agressif avec le coup eux quatre
ces tant que favori ça oui c'est mon
coup favori je change pratiquement
jamais
fischer ça m'arrive de changer quand
vraiment il ya quelque chose qui
m'embête ou où je joue pur même des fois
quand vraiment jeu j'aime bien ce que je
mon adversaire sur des cadres mais c'est
rien d'accord alors eu 4 c 5 donc
sicilienne donc ça c'est var entendu
lors c'était aussi la partie de
jean-rené c'était aussi une sicilienne
contre continue à croire est ce que tu
as tu as suivi parce que on peut citer
aussi que comme tous les joueurs jouent
au même endroit vous suivez les parties
des uns et des autres lorsque toi tu as
suivi cette partie entre laurent et en
os non absolument pas non pas du tout
donc je vais la découvrir on peut tout à
fait d'accord donc tu la regardes avec
nous en tout cas ça nous fait deux a
fait un grand maître nom de maître par
dont deux maîtres internationaux bientôt
grand maître tous les deux j'espère pour
vous qui commente avec nous cette partie
donc aux 4 c 5 donc ici une précision or
nos chars ne joue que très rarement ses
cinq puisque habituellement tu joues la
défense karo kann avec lequel il a des
résultats très solides puisqu'il
l'analyser avec karpov
oui mais disons que ces derniers temps
dans l'année 2000 il a commencé à
essayer de jouer plus agressif et jouer
à sicilienne et quand on regarde ces
derniers tournois sur la base de données
on voit que pendant l'année 2000 il a
joué aucune karo kann et il a joué que
dessine
voilà donc laurent qui est très au fait
qu'ils étaient avant la partie très
hauts faits dont tu t'attendais à une
sicilienne l'on a eues j'étais sûr
d'ailleurs c'est exactement tomber dans
ce que j'avais prévu donc c'est là qu'on
voit l'importance de la préparation des
joueurs avant avant leur parti donc eu
six cavaliers 3 1 6 peut-être laurent tu
peux vous dire à quel moment peut être
tu as été
dans dix ont placé les actions
importantes là c'est normal donc je sais
ce que c'est ce que j'avais prévu donc
j'ai joué au 4 c 5 kgs c3 disons que le
coût normal ces cavaliers 23 mai kbc 3
c'est juste c'est jugé habitude de jouer
ce coup parce que sur des six j'aime pas
trop la neige d'or donc sur des si je
jouais f4 et j'essaie de changer vu que
je joue un âge d'or fait avec des noirs
c'est dur de penser qu'une ouverture est
bonne et de jouer les blancs disons que
c'est un peu contradictoire a commencé
de caspar en plus aucun espoir on le
fait mais kasparov j'ai peut-être pas
autant à l'elysée que lui la neige dans
saisir qu'on attaque sauvage et de le
faire puisque s'ils ont joué contre nous
mêmes on serait forcément opposé à notre
propre répertoire
ouais donc alors cavaliers prend des
quatre ans huit baies 5 fu détroit je
pense que harnois est prévu saint parce
que j'avais joué j'ai déjà joué système
contre ce mirin aux championnats
d'europe à 500 en juillet donc la partie
une à une toutes façons il m'a dit après
la partie qu'il a eue cette partie dont
qui lie les deux joueurs sont à
l'impréparation d'un v6 donc attaque
locale dite des 'quatre faut faire
attention aux mises à mal a donc igor
igor nataf a joué faux 3 contre genre
n'est rien mais disons que c'était ça ma
disons chaussée avant bien sûr mais
cette vente je sais pas elle m'a pas
convaincu donc tu avais vu la partie de
jean rené et d'hier pourra vendre pour
faire que j'avais regardé un petit peu
comme on regarde les élèves grand
échiquier donc de 30 ans jette un coup
d'oeil mais j'avais vu cette vente vu
quel matériel vu que j'ai joué les
blancs d'accord donc j'en ai tu as aidé
un peu laurent se préparer si on veut
donc la suite alors donc amélie p3 donc
dames c'est cette fois ils prouvent il
remet ça d'un prix rebouche saddam à ce
que c'est normal
oui c'est normal parce que maintenant la
dame en b6 on s'aperçoit avant la dame
rb6 était mal placé je peux gagner en
tempo par exemple parfois trois et si
les noirs veulent développer leurs
cavaliers disons que la démence et 7 est
mieux placé qu'un imbécile c'est en
général et en plus il est noir veulent
jouer cavalier 6 6 e 5 directement et
donc d'abaisser cette c'est un bon coup
parce qu'en plus c'est un ça laisse les
blancs
disons les noirs vont faire en fonction
du développement des blancs d'accord
donc c'est un coup souple qui attend de
voir ce qui va se passer à tout à fait
la dame et sur cinq meilleurs 15 ans s
est d'accord donc ensuite alors petit
rock normal qu'au lycée cisson développe
ses pièces
dames 2 voilà voilà donc là en fait j'ai
adopté le sait exactement ma partie en
semi aride mais c'est déjà adopté le
plan de ce parce qu'ils comptent rochât
au grand prix du vin du sénat à paris et
donc il est joué dame de et gagner une
partie très facilement mais arnaud avait
développé son cavalier en fait il avait
a fait à peu près il avait soumis son
cas liens 1 600 x 1 700 francs bessette
mais son cavalier b8 1,17 avait encore
des six est donc là c'est un petit
changement et je pense que le cavaliere
ceci s'est mieux passé on en profite
pour rappeler que le grand prix du sénat
disponible évidemment sur canal web dans
les archives de diagonale avec donc
shirov et un joël lautier
donc on voit on verra donc une partie
qui ressemble à celle ci
alors voilà b5 non pardon cédé 6 2 6 le
dernier coup voilà f4 donc ça c'est ça
c'est un coup agressif sur les blancs
doivent jouer tôt ou tard f4 pour ces
deux réunions c'est de jouer 5 toute
façon il n'y a pas d'autre plan donc
disposition donc s'il est décidé à jouer
sa fausse et de pousser ses deux pions
comme des béliers dans le camp adverse
voilà où en tout cas font menacer
infoman a cédé pouces et on verra après
un militaire si on les pousse l'idée de
jouer eux 5 qui qui permettra aux fous
des trois d'aller éventuellement dans
certaines ventes se sacrifier sur le sur
le petit rock des noirs sur la case h7
je pense que jean rené très au courant
de ce genre d' attaque puisqu'il en a il
en a fait beaucoup avec les blancs si je
sais pas d'erreur c'est moi j'en ai donc
j'en ai tu connais cette position avec
les blancs ça ressemble à beaucoup
d'autres sicilienne les thèmes sur un
peu toujours les mêmes effectivement
ça a dû m'arriver de sacrifier en h7
mais ça fait un certain temps déjà
d'accord alors cavalli m6 food et de
alors voilà fou d'edouard sacem cook a
l'air d'un développement pas très
ambitieux comme ça du fou mais c'est
demain mais disons que moi je veux
mettre ma tour jeu une case pour tous de
mes pièces donc je mets ma tour en 1
mais comme ça si je mets mon fond 1 3 je
me laisserais peuvent 5 et donc si je
mets mon fond en d2 et en plus quand les
noirs font b4 on s'aperçoit que je bouge
mon cavalier et le fou fait pression sur
sur l'option b 4 d'accord donc c'est un
coût qui a pas là kik a l'air comme ça
pas ambitieux mais il ya une idée
positionnelle derrière de jouer tours a
eu 1 et 1,5 c'est lassant la première
idée tout à fait alors fou hausse est
normal les noirs veulent essayer aussi
de roque et ils vont pas laisser le roi
au centre n'est fini mon tour a eu donc
voilà savez toutes les pièces blanches
sont développées maintenant les blancs
sont prêts à faire une action en tout
cas voilà tout à fait alors des cartes
c'est les noirs choisissent de réagir
les premiers épisodes qu'ils ont fait
ils avaient peur en fait sur petit rang
que je joue au 5 directement vu que le
pion aux 5 et défendu et que comme l'a
dit et loi tout à l'heure que la
diagonale du fou s'ouvre voilà une
possibilité aux scènes en cadets du
tyrol et disons que je sais pas si c'est
si c'est vraiment bien pour les blancs
mais en tout cas c'est assez grave et
c'est assez désagréable pour les noirs
vu que lecavalier f6 doit partir qui
défend le rock et en plus le maintenant
le fou le fond blanc et ouvert sur le
sur l'anc
oui une position d'attaqué quand même
très très impressionnante avec toutes
les pièces qui sont prêtes à jaillir et
compliqué ces trois d'ailleurs qui peut
réduire ou quatre fois il ya beaucoup de
potentiel en fait beaucoup d'énergie
dans toutes ses pièces blanches six
mains toutes les pièces sont prêts à
attaquer le rock donc effectivement
c'est ça fait peur ce coût 1,5
donc d'où le coupé 4 finalement qui fait
une diversion
il faut bouger ce calice et 3 puis on
donc toujours pas l'adresse du roi pour
l'instant rival et qu'elle a maintenant
que la tour est un peu un c - en mettant
la les noirs répondre par 5 lille valeur
tempe et empêcher donc les blancs eux
mêmes de jouer voilà donc en fait s'il
avait joué aux cinq au coude avant je
faisais simplement caïds et 5 et c'est
pour ça qu'il n'a joué
et qu'il a joués b4 d'abord d'accord
parce qu'il arrange ou en s'inclinant il
se crée une case faible en d5
éventuellement même f5
oui bien sûr mais bon il screening
disons que s'il arrive à changer les
pions et 5 contre 4 il aura une case for
temps 1,5 alors le coup sûr et là je
vois ces cavaliers ou 300h ce coup c'est
que ça contrôler effectivement les deux
cas ce faible que se sont créés les
noirs c'est à dire à la fois de dessin
et f5 et par le pion aux quatre donc
c'est d'occasion peut jaillir le
cavalier avec des menaces voilà d'accord
alors qu'ils ont presque alors lâché
réfléchit à peu près une demi heure
donc là je me suis je me suis un peu
endormi comme ça m'est arrivé souvent
dans le tournoi et donc disons qu'ils
avaient pas y avait pas trop de
réflexion disons que j'ai infléchi
accueille des cinq au lieu de tourcoing
f4 donc à dessein cats a créé la dame
noire voilà donc cavalier prend qui a
l'air normal puis on prend cavaliers ou
il faut prendre 4 j'ai regardé cette
position je me suis dit qu'après [ __ ]
avec fouet après deux fois ci sa
position des noirs étaient suffisamment
solides et que j'avais pas de ça
méritait pas une demi heure de réflexion
certainement mais bon disons que j'étais
pas j'étais pas complètement sûr de moi
d'accord oui s'il est noir tiennent très
bien les cadors justement être le kode5
qu'elle est indélogeable ça c'est une
salaire d'être une belle position pour
les noix donc donc choisit donc de
prendre d'abord le pion f4 voilà avec la
tour et maintenant alors les noirs
essayé d'attaquer de d'embêter ce
qu'avaient les bisons que c'est
peut-être la pièce la moins bien placée
des glands pour les voilà tout à fait
mais à 5
disons que mon avis c'est une faute
disons qu'il avait peur sur petit rang
que je joue caïds et 5 est sûre ils
avaient peur dans son petit rock key des
cinq cavaliers en d5 le cas au lieu de
trois sur la classe des ce1 et
maintenance si on prend du cavalier le
pion becketts on trouve sans protection
à le clan b4 va être attaquée après eux
provient il va perdre le pion de le plan
b car voilà le fou des deux alors si la
tour est fixée à 30 sur tous d'accord et
la tour f notre donc avec l'option
d'achat qu'il ait joué à cinq
et en plus ça menace à 4 pour et on
comprend mieux l'idée de fou d2 dont tu
disais tout à l'heure que au cas où
au coca de b4 sur un petit oeil
là-dessus a je crois qu'on a perdu le
petit peu le fil gentil un petit ennui
technique mais voilà ton prendre 5 voilà
on va en bouffer cinq bons jeux de jeudi
dont je tire parti du fait qu'il ait
joué à cinq
donc il joue à 5 donc effectivement le
pion à six contrôles plus cette case des
cinq ans ce fourbe et 5 est embêtant
parce qu'il coule comme alice et en plus
maintenant je menace dame c4 avec la
dame du théâtre avec un clouage du
cavalier et cavaliers des 4 après qui
peut arriver donc c'est assez embêtant
d'accord qu'il faut qu'ils aient des
clous donc fou 17 et la cavalière 5
alors ça ça profite du fait que le foot
17 est occupé à des clous et lecavalier
6 et de cavaliers f5 donc fait pression
sur 7 sur g7 et éventuellement même des
six en tout cas il est très embêtant ce
cavalier c'est oui là je pensais que
j'étais gtd j'avais une très belle
position est d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est c'est le cas donc il peut jouer en
fait est là il a joué deux tyrans que
mais il pouvait jouer
il y avait un joli piège c'était fou
prend f5 puis on prend un f5 petit
roquet hélas il semble que je gagne une
pièce a fait après fo prend ses six
dames france et 6 faut prendre ce 6 d'un
premier set c'est ça oui mais il ya tout
8 qui perd la dame touré 8 et la dame
est prise au piège a donc en fait la
bonne variante pour les blancs c'était
au lieu de prendre ces 6 2 jo et mc 4 et
ça gagne est vraiment une pièce
voilà donc là faut pas faire d'erreur
faut jouer d'abord avant voilà un
renfoncement 6,6 je vous fais de même
ses cadres hélas cela en fit le cavalier
c6 est cloué et après vous prendre
cavaliers c'est double voilà le fou aux
7 qui va être prises c'est simple mais
voilà tout c'est à dire que même si on
défend le calice et 6 par tour assez
vite on liquide 3 ans et 6 avec vous
prendre un programme trois tours en est
une preuve fawcett à la fin avec une
gamme pièce voilà tout à fait donc faut
faire attention pour les pour les noirs
donc là ils sont embêtés non ça veut
dire s'ils ont du mal à roque et c'est
que la région ils sont justement oui là
c'est déjà le sait déjà
c'est déjà difficile c'est déjà
difficile mais d'accord donc là donc
petit rock faut prendre cavaliers alors
vous prendrez est obligé puisque le
fawcett est en prise par le cavalier
seul donc là on a super carrier
d'attaquant
loire olangi nous a appris plusieurs
fois dans l'émission on l'a vu sur sur
plein de partie que c'est le local et
kasparov kasparov aime bien que mettre
ce cas là il dit que sa voix me pions je
crois que c'est donc à tous les joueurs
aiment bien mettre leurs cavaliers là
d'accord donc cavalier viking en tout
cas on voit qu'il fait pression c'est un
an +6 ils veulent échanger genre mais un
autre alors là c'est bien tu arrives à
rossi cli la dernière pièce qui joue pas
mal et ce fameux qu'amélie b3 qui était
un peu exclu
et là tu le mets dans l'action donc il
est tout de suite tout tout tout est
bien tout est bien mais encore donc la
menace ses cavaliers prend ses six
suisses de carlier prendre cette voie là
tout à fait ou alors le contraire ou le
contraire alors fou des huit food et 8,2
en angola il enlève sans donc 2003 et
maintenant je pense que la position des
noirs simplement ferme eu d'accord d'un
f3 et l'idée c'est quoi dedans f3c de
faire un changement maintenant je menace
cavaliers pranger 7 convient à la partie
on va voir
et donc maintenant il est en fait on a
regardé beaucoup de coups ici et tous
les coups peur n'ayez déjà aidé il ya
des jolies variante donc à la place de
tours 8 on va peut-être commencer par
regarder la partie comme ça ça sera
assez on va raser la partie parce qu'on
n'aura pas le temps de tout voir
puisqu'on va essayer de voir si la
partie d'un jean rené tout à l'heure
alors en cavale et pranger sept ans la
sas alors là on va s'arrêter là parce
que ça c'est un sacrifice typique de
data que sur le roc et c'est un très
joli très joli geste technique je dirais
voilà il sait ce qui finit à partit donc
faut expliquer peut-être si on reproche
17 ce qui se passait alors qu'est ce qui
se passe sur rappelant le cavaliere je
crois qu'il ya eu un bac s qui nous
expliquait tour prend un tour prend
cavallino prendre cavaliers ont fou
prend foucras fois six échecs fois ci
c'est la cie droit prend il y aurait
d'un profond échec suivi d'un math 3,5
et cavaliers f5 avec un match assez
rapide mc rapide roanne 101 matchs en 3
coups non ce n'est pas aux frites à
d'accord j'ai pas vu le matin trois
coups avec g4g bien à dire quoi cp c'est
un gros projet 4 rapproche des 400
américains trois coups mais 25 pour un
stade car il ya trois matches donc ça
c'est donc c'est le quart eli est
imprenable
voilà donc maintenant tout reprend fou
prend des fois je suis bon si le roi
venger 6ieme f5 échec et on retombe
alors tout reprend alors cavaliers prend
fou voilà on parle de quelle variante
exactement le roi prendre
c'est la partie d'accord reprend g7 tout
reprend m6 alors oui tu veux revoir la
variante vous prendrez la fois ci ce
sont donc trois g6 change rien à f 5 et
roy g8 d'un problème 6 avec matt damon
un ranger cette toutes les variantes
possibles
non mr oui de toute façon si le roi ne
prend pas le fou on ajouté oui monsieur
de 9,5 et on va ramasser le feu donc il
fallait voir en fait il ya dans cette
combinaison il ya un sacrifice de
cavaliers après une sacrifice de qualité
par la tour et enfin encore un sacrifice
de pièces avec le fou mais c'est très
étonnant parce qu'il ya trois ans j'ai
gagné contre arnaud hauchard en les
jouant tous âges six échecs en
sacrifiant le flou sur la même case dans
le même type de rentes avec un canard en
jce est aussi aux ruines carreaux cannes
sur une quarantaine mais c'était aussi
pour dévier le roi et pour pour que
madame arrive en f c'est ce que ça veut
dire que pour gagner contre arnaud
hauchard il faut laisser chaque fois il
faut qu'ils travaillent le thème car
l'étranger cette donc tout reprend 1,4
probablement le seul tour prend 1,4
récupère le ballon fait au plus simple
cahier français si j'ai vu que ça gagner
en ligne donc cavalier prendre fou
maintenant dans prend voilà et latour
ans et ça gagne une pièce c'est ça parce
que si on prend le cavalier il ya tour
j'ai quatre échelles à tout à fait
qu'ils gagnent la dame 6,6 voilà on peut
peut-être se montrer rapidement si roy
prend cavaliers il est imprenable à
cause de tour j'ai quatre caves les
prendre pour par exemple et d'un
programme
et c'est terminé les blancs trop de
matériel d'avant ce don qui l'a fait à
fria tour donc il a préféré prendre et
autant reprendre la tour avec le
cavalier bien évidemment là c'est pareil
je fais toujours français comprend le
capitaine probable donc les blancs ont
une pièce de plus voilà ce qu'ont les
dix ans que d'une pièce de plus en plus
le roi noir et leurs honoraires
si je fais ce qu'il a fait donc il a
fait monter encore un petit échec foulée
6 échecs crois m'adresser deux tacles le
fou des 2 900 qui s'est fini là c'est ça
le 26e coup il peut encore se défend un
petit peu et dame prend b2 mais il a
vraiment une pièce de moins si ça me
prend b2 il ya tour j'ai quatre échecs
et 1 8 matches officiels à tours qui
traîne à la bat donc c'est pas très
agréable alors on voit donc on va voir
ses parents très vite parce que on avait
vu justement la lame nast ces dames g3
suite mat
voilà donc il faut faire dans prend b2
et la tour j'ai quatre échecs
voilà roi et fuite et la dame prend à 8
suivi du match fou des huit dames trois
des huit matches voilà tout à fait donc
une très jolie partie d' attaque c'est
je pense que quand tu es content de ta
création d'aujourd'hui
je suis content de ma partie de journée
disons qu arnaud hauchard père
extrêmement peu de parties donc le
battre en 26 coups c'est quand même
exceptionnel
alors il nous reste encore un peu de
temps je crois à peu près une dizaine de
minutes mois une dizaine de minutes on
va voir la partie de l'agent rené qu'il
a fait contre etienne bacrot ok alors
allons-y
jean-rené contre etienne bacrot la voilà
donc on va on va peut-être voir là
peut-être jean rené tu va nous mettre
directement sur la position critique de
cette partie j'ai pas soyez jean-rené
quelle est la position critique de cette
partie donc au début on peut on doit
s'arrêter là c'est quand même faut
mentionner que c'est un ordre de cook
etienne ne joue pas d'habitude je sais
pas trop il voulais m'entraîner en tous
les cas il m'a avoué après la partie que
il s'est pas retrouvé dans la variante
qui voulait il est vrai des six noms ici
le je pense si voulais m'entraîner dans
une chose n'a obtenu après fou et 2 par
exemple
oui mais là je peux obtenir
une vieille murovic jouant vite c'est
donc la tac avec grand roque voilà oui
donc très ambitieux faut une fois aux
trois tu as dit m6 m6 et a poussé gavras
et le typique de la deûle attaques
ennemies robic on l'appelle outil aussi
attacks auzines si je me trompe pas il
faut cette dame eux deux c'est un
système dont qui a été mis à la mode par
fisher et velits murovic puisque le
système porte son nom et yougoslaves
c'est ça je rigole voilà un très grand
joueur d'attaqué en fait donc grand
roque et les idées alors l'idée de plein
on va peut-être indiqué ça rapidement
c'est que les noirs bon tôt ou tard
devoir faire le petit rock probablement
et les blancs on va essayer d'attaquer
avec leurs pions qui ne la droite et et
le roi blanc et un de l'autre côté les
noirs vont faire de même avec leurs
pions noirs
donc c'est une attaque de pions dame et
à celle attaques violentes en fait c'est
l'interview d'un puisqu'on cherche à
mater l'adversaire en fait c'est ça oui
bon il ya 2 il ya deux variantes où ça
se passe pas exactement comme ça
notamment le caillou retard d'europe ce
qui s'est passé dans la partie là il a
joué cavalier à 5 alors là le coup le
plus théorique c'est quand même petit
rock effectivement sur quoi on peut
jouer g4 ou au tour g1
je me rappelle une très belle partie que
j'ai joué contre journée avec les noirs
je crois que j'avais gagné
cassel a mentionné quand même pour la
vérité historique que tu n'as pas gagné
alors qu'elle venait à sa garde temps
que le fougueux 3 il faut absolument
éliminer ce fouillis que tu as failli la
perdre mais c'est possible il faut
absolument éliminer le four b3 j'en ai
c'est nécessaire oui donc le lit des
deux secousses et de d'éliminer fougue
et 3 et aussi de retarder le rock comme
ça une attaque une attaque sur les
droits et moins dangereuse alors merci
d'avancé pour pas rater la flamme la
partie parce que sinon on n'aura pas le
temps donc j'ai quatre cavaliers prend
b3 à prendre mais trois alors est-ce
qu'on peut prendre du plomb c'est aussi
non à ce moment précis non parce que
lecavalier c3 serait cloué et il
pourrait jouer qui a failli prendre
quatre d'accord tout simplement
donc il faut prendre absolument du pion
rae la b5 donc les lenoir effectivement
essayé d'attaquer aussi alors on voit
que les noirs ne donne pas tout de suite
la direction de leroy ça c'est embêtant
parce qu'on sait pas trois béliers blain
s'il faut attaquer avec la tour avec les
pièces avec les pions puisque suivant où
le roi se positionne c'est pas pareil
voilà donc là le combat c'est quand même
pour l'instant pour les casses centrale
donc le prochain coup des blancs g5 vise
à chasser cavaliers du contrôle des
casses centrale d'accord le kayakiste
obligé d'aller en dix-sept donc le pion
aux 4 n'est plus attaquer la h4 donc tu
essayes de te va essayer de démolir les
trois pions noirs en face qui peuvent
protéger le petit rock
alors j'ai joué il ya très très
longtemps
il ya peut-être plus de dix ans cavalier
f5 sacrifice de pièces qui d'après les
analyses relativement douteux en fait
bien que la position soit très compliqué
cavaliers des cinq ensuite et c'est donc
j'ai pas répéter aujourd'hui je pensais
que je pensais qu'il y avait d analyse
correcte sur cette variante et il m'a
dit après la partie que non en fait
qu'ils craignaient beaucoup ce coup
cavalière simple je pense qu'il aurait
toute façon trouver des très bons coups
sur l'échiquier d'accord donc là je
choisis donc plutôt d'organes 4 cl c'est
le coup le coût théorique
ça vise à jouer h5 g6 de manière à
affaiblir le pion au no 6 et donc sur b4
l'ag j'ai joué cavalier a deux qui est
relativement inhabituel le coût normal
ces cavaliers à 4,6 là tu m'as dit avoir
regretté peut-être de jouer ce coup en
fait c'est un coup c'est un coup un peu
tendu parce que il faut aussi que les
noirs réagissent très bien ce à temps
plein de pièges et si les noirs se
trompe pas ce moment là je peux avoir
une très bonne position et vous allez
jouer sur quatre qui ces cinq noms
cavaliers c-53 b1 etc on s'écrit
figurent henri iv pas ya pas mal de
théorie là-dessus je connaissais pas
tout en plus tu vas lit à deux c'est bon
c'est un essai je sais pas c'est quand
même oui oui je suis d'accord ça semble
douteux on va avancer sur les coûts
suivants faut savoir que le coup asséné
par exemple est pas bon le ku'damm à
cinq ou six est très tendue et la haye
devant l'échiquier il a trouvé un très
bon coup mais cette pro b cette taille
là d'un adam prieur pâte à crêpes y en a
quatre c'est une contre attaque en fait
c'est une contre attaque puisque le cube
et 4 et attaquer mais ça serait con tre
en 4 ce qui serait une mauvaise
opération
oui puisque le fou après trouverez un
très bon poste d'attaquant g6 ou f5
enfin sur cette diagonale qui pilonne
ces deux entre autres f 3 des 5 des 5 et
le coup typiquement libérateur de la
sicilienne ainsi les noms arrivent à le
jouer si je sais pas c'est pas c'est pas
mauvais en général donc l'aï
effectivement il défend son pion b4 par
ce coup et en même temps ils menacent de
prendre 2 4 le fos est maintenant pro de
plage et j'ai envisagé assez longtemps
h5 et sur des pentes 4g 6 l'envoyons ça
donc il nous reste sept minutes à peu
près 30 15 n'ont pas on reprend pas en
juger si ces six et là curieusement il
peut faire simplement petit rock petit
retient la position tout va bien pour
lui oui
je vais avoir simplement un pion de
moins allez les blancs on peut dire
qu'ils virtuellement avec une pièce de
moins puisque le cavalier à deux est
absolument plus dans la partie
ouais c'est vrai aussi ce cavalia 2 qui
participent à l'action
alors autant qu'en revenant à la partie
donc tu choisi de prendre ça saigne ça
c'était pas bon prise en dessin je pense
qu'il faut le faire faut prendre les 5
et là je pense que la partie elle se
joue ici parce que c'est vrai j'ai
choisi volontairement une variante un
peu tendu si les armes si les
inconvénients se révèle plus importante
les avantages ça devient rapidement
catastrophique et c'est ce qui s'est
passé donc là il faut absolument tenter
qu'avaient les f-5 que j'ai vu
évidemment mais c'est alors avec l idée
si on prend le oui non peut pas prendre
le travail et parce qu'il va tout
reprendre il faut tout reprendre et
sainte depuis la position blanche est
tout à fait convenable parce que les
noirs ont pas encore reçues et puis le
plus sage est attaqué on vous prend b3
et l'ag envisager beaucoup de choses et
qu'il faut faire probablement ses
cavaliers projet 7 quel point j'ai cet
échec - f8 fuite et dam des trois dames
détroit qui attaquent le fou et qui sait
le coup que j'ai manqué enfin que j'ai
que j'y suis estiment certains que
cavalli 17 aussi je pensais que je
pouvais être que j'étais perdant dans
cette position et j'ai pas j'ai pas
réalisé que d'hommes détroit continuer
la partie
c'est pas mal donc ces attaques le food
et b3 le cavaly 17
alors s'il fait rien il faut prendre
cavaliers iliad en prend cavaliers et si
le roi prend un cavalier g7 c'est le fou
aux 7 quelle emprise totale était clair
tout c'est peut-être qu'il ya food et
cinq dans cette position coup d'essai
c'est le cookie faut jouer et l'ag
je joue soit chabalier h5 soif ou des
quatre je ne sais pas d'accord vous des
quatre ya peut-être un passé assez
compliqué mais je pense que c'est la
position dans laquelle je dois rentrer
d'accord donc au lieu de du coût de la
partie finale malheureusement après on a
b1
on peut dire que les blancs sont
stratégiquement perdant à cause duquel
il y en a deux elle cause du kenyan à 2
mais le kenyan à deux c'est pas le plus
grave en fait il peut toujours ressortir
par ses 1 le plus grave c'est la
structure de pions
sur les dames ses pions doublé qui
permet au noir d'ouvrir très facilement
une colonne alors que moi j'ai pas la
possibilité de l'autre côté de faire la
même chose on va regarder rapidement
c'est une
si on pouvait mais pas renié la fin ce
sera tout aussi bien donc on va quand
même voir si vous voulez trois chefs un
petit rock donc la f4 donc tu essaie
quand même de contre-attaquer vers le
rock et demi ma foi j'ai plu à beaucoup
d'autres choses à faire mais bon là je
savais déjà que et le fc peu de chance
en fait à 4 donc l'aller les noirs vont
ouvrir la position j'ai joué déjà sur
l'arctique entre olivier rooney il ya
plus de dix ans et c'était à peu près la
même si c'est malheureux de le dire mais
je comprends g7 avec le pion mais le
pion on continue à défendre de renoir
donc changer cette voie là mais le
renoir n'est pas vraiment à l'air quoi
il manque il manque un fond blanc en
fait pour combler le trou blanc ou
pouvoir mettre un cavalier en rêve 6 ou
en âge 6 et malheureusement j arrive pas
donc là bon tous les coups qui restent
ma foi il va dire des tentatives
désespérées d'essayer d'aller mater les
noirs étaient le roi mais ça ne vaut
rien alors que le roi blanc lui va va
succomber à il va faire apprend mais 3
et j'ai aucun moyen de défendre
5 ces deux minutes à la pointe de
diamant cavaliers histoire de jouer les
contours problème 5 qui en prend b3 il
faut prendre là il a 36 façons de gagner
il peut prendre ces deux peut prendre à
deux voix là et là il conclut avec une
fourchette à l'arrivée tour contours
tout reprend et kiev 4 c'est la fin
fourchette entre la dame et la tour la
dame va récupérer il ya trop de matériel
d' avance donc c'était une partie est
tendue donc il s'est décidé sur
l'ouverture il fallait il fallait un
moment donné se choisir une variante
compliqué pour pouvoir continuer la
partie basse c'est un peu comment
comment casino quoi un moment où on fait
quelque chose
un temps peut-être chose et puis on
gagne on perd c'est vrai que j'aurais pu
accepter la nulle au 9e coup c'était pas
dans ma dans mon état d'esprit
bah c'est entouré c'est tout à son
honneur d'avoir essayer de la gagner en
tout cas d'étienne macro mais dans un
point d'avancé sur iossif portman avait
une partie très très serré demain je
crois qu'on est on arrive à la fin de
notre notre émission reste deux minutes
bon laurent frayssinet demain tu joues
contre eux qui jouent comme nataf contre
igor la tête je sais encore de gagner
avec les noirs cette fois on verra je
vais essayer de jouer et de faire du
mieux que je peux mais bon je n'ai pas
de plan précis disons que je vais
essayer de jouer une bonne partie mais
voilà et jean-rené contre jean-marc deux
rêvent aussi avec les noirs donc donc
jean marc a perdu aujourd'hui donc qui
sait qui s'est malheureusement mis hors
course tout seul
on verra quelles sont ses intentions
disons que la première chose aussi avec
les noirs c'est de se défendre égaliser
et puis si les possibilités de bien par
s on les exploitera la corde et merci
encore à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cette émission et merci encore pour
vos analyses je vous dis à demain pour
le résultat final est peut-être mais le
titre de champion de france qui va
revenir à thiennes bac pro ou alors on
aura droit à un match de départage entre
le torse maniema considère pas l'emploi
merci
à